what i learned from doing 20 episodes of
this demo rpg series and teaching a
little bit of c plus
i've definitely learned some things some
things i did not anticipate learning in
fact
one of the main reasons there's two main
reasons i did this series i'll just
start with those
the first one was basically to have some
consistent content in a new series come
out
i think every channel needs that those
seem to be what have grown my channel
mostly in the past and if you're a new
youtuber i would highly advise making
some sort of series it almost
doesn't matter what it is just anything
you feel a little bit passionate about
why not make a series on it that way you
have some continued content and things
for people to keep coming back to so
that was one of the reasons but there
were other reasons i guess the other
main reason was i really wanted to just
make a library like this and i always
have there are more than two reasons now
i'm thinking about it i've always wanted
to make this sort of library just for
the fun of it really i just always
thought it would be fun to do this
and so i was kind of killing two birds
with one stone there i
well even more
because i also wanted to find a way to
teach c plus plus that wasn't just going
through a list of here the different
things you can do i wanted an actual
project so that would be the third thing
so yeah having a consistent series i've
always wanted to make a library of this
rpg stuff
and
just being able to teach c plus plus in
a way that was a little
different those were my main aspirations
here
and i settled on doing 20 episodes so
what did i learn in these 20 episodes oh
boy i learned a lot a lot more than i
thought i would we started on january
24th that's when the first one was
released i figured it would take about a
month and we did the last episode on
march 6th so in episode one i learned
that uh you need to zoom in people can't
just magically read tiny text there were
a lot of comments about i can't read
anything but overall i was just kind of
spitting the idea i had and people
seemed to
resonate with that so that was kind of
cool i wasn't sure if people would or
not
and in episode two and three i was
starting to get into adding some some
classes and levels and
just some general work and i started to
realize that there were a lot of people
who were aware of c plus plus stuff that
i wasn't which is
totally expected i guess in some way or
another but i wasn't expecting to run
into
things where i needed to go do research
i i kind of went into this thinking i
know how to do all this already but
you'll always be surprised there's
always more to learn with c plus plus
and that was one of the things there was
a some comments about
use composition over
inheritance and i was like okay maybe i
need to look into this more because i
seem to be using inheritance a bit much
and they were right so in episode 4 i uh
corrected that to some extent and tried
to use it better going forward but there
were definitely some important lessons
there about that and it really made me
kind of rethink my design entirely and i
actually had to take a little time off
let's see what there were two days in
between these commits so it took like a
couple days i was planning on doing like
an episode a day but there were some
times when i needed a couple days
and it looks like between episode 8 and
9 i took more
but also some other things started to
come up here and i started to realize
that there is just going to be people
that aren't going to be happy no matter
what i do creative decisions are often
roadblocks and sometimes you just got to
make a decision
and go forward and try to document it
maybe leave a comment or two so that was
like the big takeaways was basically to
not get stuck in creative decisions
and don't worry about what people are
gonna think or say because
they might be right for them but they're
not necessarily right for you and
sometimes people are just like
bitter and annoyed and leave comments as
so i kind of just i kind of started to
see around 11 12 i started thinking
what if this stuff doesn't work right
and that's where i realized i really
need tests and i really need to make
this a library that i can test that
seemed to be pretty critical and i've
also realized when i started doing this
that
a lot of programmers
just totally skipped the test phase and
it's understandable why especially in
game development usually usually your
game is the test
however
when you're playing your game you're
rarely testing your edge cases and when
they do come up if you haven't handled
them you're going to get a crash or some
weird thing is going to happen in your
game and that's that's actually quite
critical so you should make tests no
matter what
and that's a really important takeaway
that i think more people need to
embrace i'd say there's just there's
just so many times when people uh are
making stuff and
and just want to get it done so they
skip over the test i'm trying to think
of a great analogy but there really
isn't one you just have to have tests
it's it's way more important than you
realize especially with critical
applications if you're just coding for
fun it's not so big of a deal
but it makes people take your program a
lot more seriously and i made a whole
video on that so you can check that out
if you want
now there's somewhere in here in like
between february 22nd to february 24th
where i basically
took time off the series and just
refactored things and
made a bunch of tests
and that was a pretty critical moment
because well it took a lot of time but
there wasn't a whole lot to teach other
than you should be designing first if
you want to start a new project
you can't just sit down and code well
you can and that's what i did with this
i literally just sat down and started
coding
with just the idea of i want to make an
rpg i didn't really have a big plan
nothing sketched out or anything like
that and i tend to operate like that but
that's just me
most people can't operate like that i go
in i i kind of know the end goal of
where i want to get
to but
the step-by-step little minute things i
kind of just make up as i go what the
heck is my green screen dude stop
stop
so
yeah i think in the future i'm going to
try to plan a little better however you
can't always plan there's always little
things that come up so i think keeping a
notepad handy
just one of these anything and just
jotting down any little things you know
you need to work out making things to
check off seems to be helpful but i can
never maintain that do any of you guys
have the same problem like i go to start
making a list and i'll start jotting
things down and i'll stick with it for
like one day and then the next day i
just i don't care about my list anymore
i'm just gonna go to work episode 15 and
on this is where things started becoming
different for the series this is
basically where i started implementing
the library as an actual piece of
software as an actual program that you
could run basically i put in monsters
and battles first and turn it into sort
of a battle arena and started making
items drop and making sure you could use
items and then use abilities and then we
basically ran out of time we got the
episode 20 that's as far as we were
planning to go for this series but the
whole point of the series was that
by going this far and taking all these
little steps you'll learn all kinds of
new things and learn how you can do it
on your own learn how you can expand it
on your own memory management is really
important and that you should probably
be using shared and unique pointers
wherever you can
because there were a lot of these
episodes where i was spending a lot of
time just wrapping my head around what
was happening with the data and the
pointers and that has definitely made a
lot easier with unique pointers although
there's a whole learning curve to those
as well but i guess that was the main
takeaway is
yeah design the library with
the memory management in mind of how you
want to use it and that there is a lot
of different ways you might want to use
it in general for this we wanted to
there were some really important things
like we want to make sure you can't dupe
items we want to make sure
that uh
there aren't multiple references to the
same item being owned and things like
that
basically because we wanted to reduce
the amount of bugs in the game where you
could cheat and just like you know do
random stuff like dupe items or get
way more of something than you should
have so there was a lot of that in mind
and that was the big takeaways i think
for the final episodes was just
carefully managing uh your resources
and your loops uh yeah your loops are
super important in a game too
when you look at it from like a bird's
eye perspective and it's just a bunch of
while loops here and there and then
charts all over the place it's really
hard to grasp but when you dig in and
just go step by step it's not so bad
because most mainly there's one main
while loop and in that while loop
occasionally you get in other little
loops if you're doing this for a while
or you're doing that for a while but
you're still in this core
big one
so yeah i guess that's it
you